hello and thank you for watching this
talk so I'm going to talk about improved
monody testers via hack into the
mattings this is Joint work with
another Kindle
so let's get going
so we're going to start with describing
the Montana testing program and we're
going to start with the most classical
domain it has been studied on which is
the uniform hyper Cube
so what is the help you well you look at
the set of vectors zero one to the N
this is going to be all the nine and you
equip it with a password order
so in the partial Order X is less or
equal to Y if and only if x i is less or
equal to y r if all coordinates are here
and once you have the partial order you
can Define mountainousity testing in
natural y
so a function on the helpful is called
Marathon if one of the x is also equal
to y
because that f of x is less or equal to
F of Y
in other words f is to respect the
bachelor
and once you have the partial order and
multiplicity you can Define the market
ing
problem
so in this problem you're given an
orchid access to a function f to a
Boolean function on the half Cube
and this function is form is either to
be monotone
or else it's almost
and the measure of distance here is the
normalized chemical distance meaning the
distance between F and monoton is you
take the minimum of all function G
which are one corner you current the
number of inputs X on which f and g
differ on and you divide it by the total
number of points on the hyperq which is
2 to the angle
so if destruction is at least Epsilon
then we say that f is at least Epsilon
form
and for this talk you should think of
Epsilon that is more constant you can do
anything with depends in epsilon but
it's a bit annoying so we don't want to
do it
and the question is how many okay access
queries do you need to make 12 in order
to distinguish between these two cases
that is you want to design an algorithm
that makes as few query access as
possible to it
and accepts with 481 if f is monotone
whereas it rejects with probability plus
one if f is Epsilon far from
okay
so I'm already testing has been around
for a while in fact for over 20 years it
was first introduced in a battle by
who also gave an off and quality test
for the problem
and this texture is a very natural and
very nice one it's called The Edge
tester
and in that you just speak two points X
and Y that differ on exactly one
coordinate chosen randomly
you query this value of f on these two
points and you will check if these two
values violate monotonicity
so it's a very natural tester and the
analysis of blood that is very very nice
and this is the best you can do if you
only consider head testers
and it took a while to move overcome
this tester in fact over 10 years until
the check about it just also showed
different test though
which achieves query complexity into the
seven overrides
so the vessel is different the tester is
what is called tough tester
so again it's some base taster that only
does two queries which is then repeated
the most times
and the base test desktop just takes two
points X and Y that in this case they
are not
different I'm only one quarter but other
different on several components between
one and many
so they already had to kind of open a
new test but in the real interesting
thing in this work is the analysis of
the test
[Music]
which they had to prove and then used in
order to analyze this path tester that I
just mentioned
and following it all the analysis of the
test was involved by genital and over to
enter the 5 over 6.
so really the tester and the analysis
and how do the same they still use
nobody's as a moment inequality and in
fact this is the best you can do
as long as you're only using more
goodies that directed version's office
of automatic inequalities
and if you have years after that
together with code and software we
managed to improve upon this result in
both end test error
so this tester was again after so very
similar to the one by Jacob Watkins and
the real this the real differences
between this work and the previous works
is that we use a different uh
isothermic inequality in particular in
that work will pull a directed version
of initial climatic inequality due to
telegram which is stronger than the
variant final bullies and we used it to
design a tester and analyze it
and because the root n is the best you
can do at least as far as non-adaptive
test results are concerned due to work
with visual power this finishes the
discussion about monotonicity testing
over the hypercube because the context
is exactly 18th of maybe up to coil
levels
so what I'm going to talk about today is
how about in his testing although other
domains
so what do you mean by other domains
well you can consider any particular set
and start the modernity testing problem
overloads
but I would like to argue that to get
interesting results in a little bit more
structure because you know partially
overload search can be very wild and
it's not clear what you can even say
about huh
so in this work we'll consider what is
called Product domains
which is you have some basic domain
some basic probability space and comma
meal so we should think of Ms constant
the case of the help cube is just n
equals to
but you should think of M as like 10 or
200 or something like that in the mirror
some probability distribution level n
and you should think of M as being
equipped with the order in which is
natural zero less than one is two less
and so on and so forth
and once you have this you can tenderize
this space in order to get m to the N
equipped with the product measure mu to
them
and then you can discuss mountainous
testing over this product domain
so you have the partial ordering induced
by the basic partial order
you have the notion of Multiplicity and
the only thing that you need to Define
is the notion of distance from
magneticity and this is defined on the
slider so the distance between F and
welcome with respect to Major mu is the
minimum of all the momentum function G
of the measure of the set of points X on
which f and g differing
so usually if you think of mu as uniform
but it's not always going to be the case
and I'm going to mention when it is not
going to be the case
so once you look at this problem and
especially if you are familiar stand
what with the hairstyles for the hyper
tube
some testers immediately spring to mind
when we look at this domain which is
called the hyperboleader
so the clear analogs of the edge test of
gold or fatal as well of the black
thrusters
but the slightly annoying thing is that
it's not clear how to analyze them
so what is clear that these are supposed
to be the right testers
the analysis that we had for helping
Cube does not generalize or at least we
don't know how good analysis very easily
to the hyper medium
so that's there is an exception of the
quote of quality hotel which is kind of
easy to generalize to the applicator and
therefore we did know often for a
complexity test and that followed the
approach but up until 2018 this is the
best that was known
so that was the case until a few years
ago where black Jacob Institute
show that you can improve on the goal of
central results again and indeed there
is an end to the 506 for a complexity
tester for testing multiplicity over the
uniform hyperlane
and interestingly what they managed to
do in this world is they did manage to
generalize some of the directed
isothermic inequalities from the cube to
the hyperloos
and more specifically they managed to
generalize the norbury stamp is a
problematic inequality due to chakra and
then converted it into a tester in the
same way
so the real novelty here is uh that they
managed to prove the ease of American
inequality over the hybrid and this is
very non-trivial so it's it's not it's
not like uh not the same proof but you
you need to do some other points
and probably what you expect me to say
now is that in this work we managed to
improve this result the square root of M
and to do that we just generalized the
talagon style is operating qualities
but I would like to say that but the
issue is that I don't know how to
generalize the proof and sort of the
issue is the proof that we're for the
Boolean Cube was very specific to the
Boolean Cube so in that move we're to
Define some operators that have no clear
analogs for the help of the river and
therefore the wolf seem to be very
Italian to the cube
so I'm not going to say that but
nevertheless I'm going to tell you that
in this work we do manage to get off
Spotify quite complexity testers for the
uniform Hyperbole and in fact you can do
any product measure as you like
and as a byproduct we also get that
delivers on the climatic inequalities in
the style of television
and
what is very different from the previous
approaches is that the poof so we're not
trying to generalize some facts about
they will learn how to cube and instead
we take a different route
what we do in this work is we manage to
do a reduction between testing
multiplicity of hypergradle to testing
modernity over the hypercube
namely
the main goal in our world is we're
given a function f over the hyperlito
and we wish to construct the function
Gene over a slightly larger hyperculum
of Dimension environment
and we want the following properties
we want that
equally access
for Gene can be simulated by core access
to f
secondly we want this transformation to
conserve distance from Modern density
in particular if f is
and if f is far from Modern then we want
D to be also start for month only
and lastly we went to the dimension n
Prime of the G function to be not too
much louder than the dimension of x and
in particular we would like to be and
maybe tell me some polling logs of n
and if indeed you managed to find
such construction of Gene that satisfies
all of this properties you can simulate
the multination desktop 4G using coil
access fourth and you can show that this
will test monotony cd4f and the core
complexity would be a lot of N1 which is
the same model of the root of n because
we want the dimension to be roughly the
same
foreign
and of course now the question is how do
you do this reduction
so in the rest of the talk I'm going to
illustrate how you do it for the case of
the device which is again something on
the helper Cube but with a different
measure and then I'm going to say a few
words on how you do it for the
hyperdinance
very concrete
Cube we're going to consider the quarter
bicycle
so here again we have 0 1 but now we
have a different measure on it we have
the measure mu quarter which assigns one
over the quarter and zero probability
three photos
and what we want to do is we want to
reduce
testing multiplicity of such measures to
that oval uniform means
and when you look at this especially the
number quarter the natural idea that
comes to mind is the following
so if I take two uniform base X One X
two you know you take a product of them
then I would get a bit which is
bias quarter
so let's try to use this fact in order
to Define our function G
so indeed we're going to define a
function G which has a dimension which
is double dot of f
and when it gets the input x 1 to X to n
it's going to compute the pelvis
products X1 X2 X3 X4 and so on and so
forth
get an end Vector string and plug in it
to s
so this is going to be our construction
of G that attempts to simulate a quarter
by uniform base
and indeed you can show that if you want
to also Quality quality G you can
simulate it by equals to F which is
clear adjustment definition
and secondly it's also included if f is
monotone then this one also
in what seems like it should be the case
but it's not completely clear is what
happens if f is far from
in that case we would like to say that g
is from for monotone and you know this
makes a lot of sense like you know all
of this simulation here seems to be the
correct way
and it seems true but how do you show it
and the issue here is that we don't have
many tools to show that something is
powerful modeling
so let's try to do it nevertheless
so we have this function Gene that we
defined on the previous chapter
and we want to show that if f is sub for
Martin then G is far from
well equivalently it means that we want
to show that if G is close to monoton
then f is close to 1. so so far we
didn't do anything this is logically
equivalent
but now we have an assumption we have an
assumption the G is close to monotone
meaning there is some function H which
is monoton on Dimensions which is close
to G
and our body life is to show that f is
first on an opponent and it only makes
sense that we're going to do it by
constructing explicitly the function H
by in dimensional
which is monoton and close to us
and really all that we have in order to
construct H Prime is this little H about
so how we're going to use it well we
want to Define H Prime of 4 here where Y
is some input from 0 1 to the n
and we only have eight in our hand
so the only thing that we can do is
generate from y some input X of
Dimension 2 and 2H and then Define H
Prime y to be h of x
so
you know to go from
F to G we apply the snap that sends X1
to have X2 to the power of x 1 x 2. and
now in some sense we want to go the
other way so it makes sense that if you
have this Y and you want to generate X
you should use the pullback according to
this map
so what do I mean
well if y1 is equal to one then you
really have no choice you must take x 1
and x to the coordinates corresponding
to y1 to be one one
but what if y1 is equal to zero
so in that case there are three options
one zero zero one and zero zero
and it's not clear which one of them to
pick
so pick one of the middle from a random
to be more precise what you're going to
do is for each coordinate I you're going
to pick v i which is either 0 0 1 0 0 1
independently of the rest of the
coordinates
and this is going to be the pullback of
zero on that coordinates
and once you have made this choice for
each coordinate you can Define the
pullback map corresponding this choices
which pulls the one back to one one and
pulls zero back to VI
and once you have that you have this
Association from y to X you can Define
the function H Prime as a barrel
and if you carry out a simple
calculation you can show the in
expectation of the choice of the
pullback the distance between H by M and
F is the same as the distance between H
and G which is most Delta
and you can also observe that H Prime is
always one
so therefore it means that f is Delta
custom and well done
so this indeed shows that you introduce
autobias to unbiased Cube
and in a similar way you can actually do
any device Cube for p which is power of
2.
and once you have that and you use some
other Elementary manipulations you can
actually get any P bias that you would
like and the coil complexity is still
over
but these ideas I presented it seems
very specific to the
um
and it's not really what to do about
larger alphabets
so to see what to do about a lot of the
alphabets you have to sort of you know
take a step back and see what was really
happening in this argument and what made
it work
and really the point of this argument is
that we had a two-way
with one way to go from zero one squared
to mean quarter by taking the product
operation
and then we also had this pullback
automation that goes from y to one of
this well X1 X2 that made that product
into one
and
this this map said to satisfy
mysteriously several properties so that
to preserve measures and all of that
but additionally there to be monotone
this is really the property that we used
in the proof so for the product and
maybe it's clear that if you take X1 X2
and Mappy to X2 this is
and for the pullback it's also clear but
it's a bit hidden under the surface so
for every choice of VI that you might
uh the pullback operation that you get
is awesome
so with this in mind can you construct
embeddings for the hyper data Maybe
through the ground
and once you think about it this way
there is a very natural attempt that you
may do which is called a threshold
embedding
so here you're going to attempt to
partition 0 1 to the L into three parts
according to the Hamming blade
and try to make it as equal as possible
and indeed if you think about it for a
little bit and use some estimates you
can show the indeed you can partition
the cube into three roughly equal parts
and you use this specials as on the
slider
and this monotone and you have a
pullback and all of this is very good
the only issue is that it's not actually
possible to make this threshold function
partition the cube industry equal parts
and in fact it will always be the case
that one of the parts will be at least
somewhat off
so trivially you can achieve one over
one hour and if you walk a little bit
harder you may improve that a little bit
but this cannot give us like exploration
you know
a distance from uniform
and when you think about that this means
that the hour that you're going to take
him is going to be large which is going
to lead to a blowout in the dimension
which we don't want because it effects
are quite complexity
so nonetheless and this is where most of
the heavy lifting in the paper is we
show that you can take this roughly this
construction
and slightly Shuffle it and do stuff to
it in order to balance it out so that it
partitions a cube into three roughly
equal parts in a way that preserves
mountainicity as well as the pullback of
the properties
and to prove that
we use a notion which is called monitor
matchings which is you know matchings
that are only taking mark on edges or
Mountain pairs on the hypercube and this
is what most of the world goes in
formally speaking what we really have to
call is that you can partition the happy
cubing three roughly equal parts as
equal as
they can be because you know three is an
odd number
so that between any two parts there is a
perfect monotone matching
and in fact you can do it for any number
of any constant number of Parts there's
nothing special about three and this is
how we construct embeddings for the
helpline
so this is how we pull our results and
you know called current work black Jacob
one is really managed to over the side
result
information
so the tester is really the same but the
analysis is completely different
so they follow the same framework as in
the hypercube except that in their work
they managed to directly generalize The
Talented style either for medical
inequalities for the cube and then use
it to construct the desktop
but you know this takes some serious
problem indeed they do some non-trivial
work
so this seems like it finishes off these
two Works finish off the monotonous
testing problem over the hyperboleo
except that well if you really want to
completely finish it there is one more
case that you have to consider which is
what is the dependency on the alphabet
cells
so both our work and this work of
blackjack about installer you get
polynomial dependency on the alphabet
size m
and some other works that say that you
only need to consider a multiple number
size in fact you can do a Dimensions you
know
so it would be interesting to know if
the polynomial dependency on M is
necessary or maybe it can be involved
and for all we know you can do with
logarithmic dependency unit but these
two works very organic
and another interesting question is
whether there are some other domains in
which it would be interesting inside the
monopolysis testing
so uh
to make it interesting it would have to
be something which is not important
domain that's an interesting measure
within a structure you know maybe
something from statistical physics maybe
daising model who knows
so that's all thanks